a simple wish for a parent for toys like
this to be safe for their child but a
staggering 99.7 of all products entering
the internal market go unchecked
0.3 of all the goods
on the european market is checked by the
authorities that's nothing it's really
difficult to find the dangerous products
out there so we need to improve this
situation an eu rapid alert system has
been in place since 2010 but 10 percent
of faulty goods identified can't be
traced back to manufacturers a new
regulation has passed the first post of
approval at the plenary in strasbourg
the first key change setting up a
pan-european database on dodgy gear
more stringent checks on child-related
products
and blacklisting cowboy manufacturers
but one big sticking point is mandatory
country of origin labeling the house
majority says it will increase
transparency traceability and put an end
to unfair competition but for the
liberals when a european wide quality ce
mark already exists it's making europe a
nanny state does eu safety tested
markings
foreign
but the argument over country of origin
or made in labeling is a distraction
there were a number of speeches
yesterday that talked about made in in
terms of sort of economic economics
importance the european economy and so
on but i mean those aren't actually part
of consumer product safety and a message
from consumer groups was to stop the
bickering as the changes on the table
will make drastic change a lot of
products that maybe come from outside
the eu will in the future be taken off
the market earlier meaning they don't
reach consumers this is good for the
consumer this is also good for
manufacturers who invest a lot into the
safety of product but until member
states give it their backing consumers
and manufacturers may have a weight
ahead